Bonjour à tous !
Aujourd'hui on va s'intéresser aux ordinateurs quantiques
Alors les ordinateurs quantiques ça fait déjà un moment qu'on en entend parler
mais il semblerait que depuis quelques mois les choses se soient accélérées
et on pourrait bien être à l'aube d'une nouvelle ère pour l'informatique.
On va donc essayer de comprendre ce que c'est un ordinateur quantique,
comment ça marche, ce qu'on peut faire avec,
et puis si on a bientôt une chance d'en avoir un chez soi.
Avant de parler d'ordinateur quantique on va juste prendre deux minutes pour rappeler comment fonctionne un ordinateur normal.
Pas au niveau des logiciels, mais d'un point de vue fondamental.
Vous savez certainement que dans ses circuits, un ordinateur manipule l'information sous forme binaire :
des 0 et des 1.
Alors à notre niveau on s'en rend pas compte mais tous les nombres, la musique, les images...
tout ce qui défile sur votre écran
c'est stocké quelque part sous forme de 0 et de 1.
L'avantage du binaire, c'est que c'est facile à représenter du point de vue électrique :
vous prenez un fil électrique ; si le courant passe, c'est un 1, s'il ne passe pas, c'est un 0.
Et c'est ça qu'on appelle un bit.
Il existe plein d'autres manières physiques de réaliser des bits.
Ça peut être des trous dans une carte perforée,
ou bien la magnétisation à la surface d'un disque dur
mais bon, dans un circuit d'ordinateur, ce qu'on utilise, c'est le courant électrique.
Alors à notre niveau, quand on fait faire quelque chose à un ordinateur,
il utilise des algorithmes, qui généralement prennent un certain nombre de données en entrée
et fournissent des sorties.
Et ça c'est le cas, que vous soyez en train de regarder un film, de surfer sur internet,
d'écrire un texte ou de faire tourner une simulation numérique.
Et comme au niveau des circuits ces données sont sous forme binaire,
un algorithme se réduit finalement à une suite d'instructions
permettant de traiter et manipuler des bits.
Les briques de base avec lesquelles on peut manipuler l'information sous forme binaire
sont ce qu'on appelle des portes logiques.
Il s'agit des opérations élémentaires qui permettent d'agir sur les bits.
La plus simple c'est la porte "not", c'est la négation.
C'est une porte qui va simplement inverser la valeur d'un bit.
Et on peut représenter son action par un petit tableau de ce genre (voir ci-dessus)
Autre exemple, la porte "et".
Cette porte prend deux bits en entrée et en possède un en sortie.
Le bit de sortie vaudra 1 uniquement si les deux bits d'entrée sont à 1.
Et dans tous les autres cas, il sera 0.
Et voici le tableau qui représente cette porte.
Il existe plusieurs autres portes logiques élémentaires, et je vais pas toutes vous les décrire,
mais ce qui est important c'est que les opérations dont on a l'habitude
comme l'addition, la multiplication...
sont toutes faisables à partir d'un assemblage de portes logiques.
Et avec seulement quelques types de portes, on peut faire un ordinateur
L'autre chose extrêmement importante, c'est que ces portes logiques, on sait les fabriquer physiquement.
Là je vous les ai décrites de manière abstraite, mais on sait les réaliser en utilisant des composants électroniques,
et notamment des transistors.
Par exemple une porte logique "et" sera réalisable avec deux transistors, de la manière ci-contre.
Et c'est pour ça qu'un microprocesseur, c'est essentiellement un gros paquet de transistors câblés entre eux,
qui permettent de réaliser des portes logiques, et de manipuler l'information sous forme binaire
Aujourd'hui les microprocesseurs peuvent contenir jusqu'à
plusieurs milliards de transistors pour les plus puissants.
Ça c'était pour l'ordinateur normal,
passons maintenant à l'ordinateur quantique.
On l'a vu, le job de base d'un ordinateur est de manipuler des bits,
qui valent 0 ou 1.
L'idée d'un ordinateur quantique, c'est d'utiliser des bits quantiques, on appelle ça des q-bits.
Les q-bits sont des bits qui obéissent aux lois de la mécanique quantique,
et notamment à un principe fondamental :
le principe de superposition.
Ce principe nous dit qu'un objet quantique peut se trouver dans une superposition de plusieurs états.
C'est-à-dire qu'un q-bit n'est pas seulement soit dans l'état 0, soit dans l'état 1,
mais il peut être dans une superposition des deux.
En quelque sorte, dans les deux états à la fois.
Vous avez sans doute déjà entendu parler du chat de Schrödinger,
qui serait à la fois mort et vivant.
En fait, c'est pas vrai, parce qu'en pratique les chats quantiques n'existent pas,
un chat, c'est bien trop gros.
Mais si on prend un objet suffisamment petit qui peut être dans deux états,
il peut se comporter comme un bit quantique et obéir au principe de superposition.
On va prendre un exemple :
vous savez peut-être que les électrons possèdent un spin.
Alors le spin c'est une longue histoire, mais essentiellement ça conduit les électrons à se comporter comme des petits aimants,
qui, quand on les met dans un champ magnétique,
peuvent être orientés, soit dans un sens, soit dans l'autre.
Eh bien un spin peut faire office de q-bit, il est dans un état,
dans l'autre, mais il peut être aussi dans une superposition des deux.
En mécanique quantique on utilise la notation ci-dessus pour dire qu'on superpose des états.
Alors quel est l'intérêt d'avoir un q-bit plutôt qu'un bit classique ?
Imaginons que vous ayez un calcul à faire et qu'on vous demande de faire ce calcul successivement
en prenant comme donnée d'entrée le nombre 0
puis le nombre 1.
Avec un système classique, vous allez devoir faire le calcul deux fois, une fois avec 0 en entrée, une fois avec 1.
Maintenant si en entrée vous avez un q-bit,
qui est une superposition de 0 et de 1,
vous allez faire d'un seul coup les deux calculs,
vous faites une seule opération au lieu de deux.
Alors est-ce que c'est ça un ordinateur quantique ?
Un ordinateur qui fait deux opérations au lieu d'une et qui calcule deux fois plus vite ?
Eh bien non. C'est pas si simple mais c'est aussi beaucoup plus que ça.
Avec un ordinateur classique, quand on représente des nombres
On utilise pas un seul bit, sinon on ne pourrait représenter que zéro ou un
Mais on associe plusieurs bits pour former ce qu'on appelle un registre
Si vous utilisez un registre de quatre bits, voici toutes les configurations qu'il peut adopter
0000, 0001, 0010, 0100, etc
En tout, il y a 16 états possibles pour le registre.
Qui permettent donc de représenter des nombres entre 0 et 15
Maintenant, imaginez un registre quantique fait de 4 q-bits
bah, il peut être dans une superposition de ces 16 états
et c'est même encore plus que ça, parce qu’on peut mettre des coefficients sur les états comme pour varier les proportions
de manière schématique, être dans 16 états à la fois, ça permet de faire 16 calculs en parallèle
Et si on avait un registre de 8 q-bits, il pourrait être dans une superposition de 256 états
et donc aller 256 fois plus vite
De manière général, si on prend un registre de n q-bits, il permet d'aller 2^n fois plus vite que l'équivalent classique
On estime, aujourd'hui, qu'avec 1 seul registre d'une vingtaine de q-bits, on pourra atteindre la puissance d'un ordinateur normal
Une quarantaine de q-bits, on serait au niveau du plus gros ordinateur qui existe
Et avec 100 q-bit, bah, je vous laisse faire le calcul
Un point important à avoir en tête, c'est qu'un ordinateur quantique, c'est pas magique
ça permet pas de faire des choses qu'on pourrait pas faire avec un ordinateur classique
ça va juste plus vite, ça accélère les calculs
Enfin.. certains calculs
Parce que contrairement à ce que j'ai laissé sous entendre, on ne peut pas tout accélérer avec un ordinateur quantique
et on ne va pas les utiliser de la même manière qu'on utilise un ordinateur normal
mais pour comprendre ça, il faut se plonger dans la manière dont on les programme, ces fameux ordinateurs quantiques
Je vous l'ai dit, avec un ordinateur normal, on effectue des opérations en manipulant des bits à l'aide de portes logiques
qu'on sait réaliser, par exemple, avec des transistors
Si maintenant, vous utilisez des q-bits, et bien il va falloir changer de circuit, ça va plus marcher
il va falloir utiliser des portes spécifiques, les portes quantiques
Les portes quantique permettent de manipuler des q-bits et de faire avec eux des opérations qu'on pourrait pas faire avec des portes logiques normales
Juste pour donner un exemple
Prenons la porte qu'on appelle la porte de Hadamard
Alors, elle prend 1 q-bit en entrée et en donne 1 en sortie
Et elle est telle que si le q-bit d'entrée n'est pas dans une superposition, il vaut par exemple 1
bah le q-bit de sortie, lui, sera dans une superposition moitié/moitié de 0 et de 1
Alors je vous épargne les détails mais il existe toute une zoologie de portes quantiques qui permettent de manipuler des q-bits
et qui prennent en entrée et en sortie, 1, 2, 3 q-bits voire beaucoup plus
Pour les férus de maths, on représente ces portes quantiques par des matrices (unitaires les matrices)
mais il y a quand même un point essentiel pour comprendre le fonctionnement d'un ordinateur quantique
et qui explique pourquoi on ne peut pas faire n'importe quoi avec
Je vous ai dit, tout à l'heure, qu'un ordinateur quantique, c'est un peu comme avoir un grand nombre d'ordinateurs normaux qui fonctionneraient en parallèle
mais en fait, c'est pas tout à fait ça
Si vous avez plein d'ordinateurs normaux, vous pouvez les faire travailler sur des trucs qui n'ont rien à voir entre eux
ou leur faire faire chacun un calcul et récupérer tous les résultats à la fin
avec un ordinateur quantique, c'est pas possible, parce qu’à la fin, vous ne pourrez avoir, de toute façon, qu'un seul résultat
C'est lié à un principe quantique qui s'appelle " la réduction du paquet d'onde"
et qui dit que qu'on a un état superposé, on ne peut pas le connaitre en entier
la seul chose qu'on puisse faire, c'est de le mesurer et, dans ce cas là, on le réduit à une seule de ses composantes
donc même si un ordinateur quantique peut faire plein de calculs en parallèles
à la fin, il va vous donner qu'une seule réponse, donc on ne peut pas l'utiliser pour calculer plein de trucs et ramasser tous les résultats
Un ordinateur quantique sera donc toujours moins polyvalent que son équivalent en ordinateur classique
et c'est seulement que certains types de problèmes qu'il pourra vous faire bénéficier de son pouvoir d'accélération
Pour ça, il faut des problèmes pour lesquels on sache trouver un algorithme spécifique, un algorithme quantique, fait de portes quantique
qui sera différent de l'algorithme classique
mais qui permet d'exploiter cette idée de parallélisme, uniquement dans les calculs intermédiaires, mais en ne donnant qu'un seul résultat à la fin
Prenons un problème pour lequel ça marche pas mal
alors le problème à résoudre est le suivant :
Imaginez que vous ayez une fonction, f, qui, à un entier,  associe un autre entier
on peut la représenter sous forme d'un tableau
et imaginons que je vous demande, par exemple, de trouver l'entier qui par la fonction donne le nombre disons... 42
Algorithme classique, bah, il y a pas pas trop le choix, vous regarder une par une les lignes du tableau jusqu'à trouver le bon
si vous avez n lignes dans le tableau, il vous faudra , au maximum, n étapes
Avec un ordinateur quantique, il existe un algorithme, l'algorithme de Grover, qui permet  d'aller plus vite en regardant des superpositions
et qui permet de trouver la solution en seulement racine de n étape
si vous avez 1 millions de lignes dans votre tableau, bah l'algorithme quantique ne prend que 1000 étapes, au lieu de 1 million
il va donc 1000 fois plus vite
C'est pas mal, non ?
Mais gardez en tête, qu'il existe des problèmes pour lesquels, on ne connait pas voire il n'existe pas d'algorithme quantique qui soit plus rapide que l'algorithme classique
donc avoir un ordinateur quantique, c'est pas la garanti absolue que tous les calculs se trouvent accélérés
Mais voyons un exemple, pour lequel, justement, ça marche extrêmement bien
et qui est un peu l'archétype des problèmes qu'on espère résoudre avec des ordinateurs quantiques
il s'agit de la factorisation des nombres entiers
Factoriser un nombre, c'est trouver sa décomposition en un produit de nombres premiers
par exemple : 70, bah c'est 2 fois 5 fois 7
48 279, c'est 3 fois 7 fois 11 au carré fois 19
Alors ce problème ne vous parait pas très compliqué, il suffit de faire ça comme un bourrin et de diviser successivement par les nombres premiers (2, 3, 5 etc)
Mais quand les facteurs premiers sont grands, bah c'est plus dur
par exemple, 56 153, à votre avis, ça se décompose comment ?
Et bien, c'est 233 fois 241, pas si simple à trouver.
Ce problème de factorisation en nombre premier, il est très important
parce-que c'est la dessus que se base un certain nombre d'algorithmes de cryptographie, comme par exemple l'algorithme RSA, qui est très utilisé.
Pour craquer un chiffrage RSA, bah sur le papier c'est assez simple
il suffit de trouver la décomposition en facteur premier d'un nombre très grand
genre un nombre comme celui-la, alors en théorie, trouver la décomposition pose pas vraiment de problème, il suffit de faire plein, plein de divisions
mais en pratique, si on voulait vraiment faire ce calcul, même avec l'ordinateur le plus puissant du monde et bah ça prendrait un temps démentiel.
Et c'est ça qui protège la sécurité des communications qui sont chiffrées avec un algorithmes de type RSA.
Pour quantifier le temps et les ressources mémoires dont a besoin un algorithme pour faire un calcul, on parle de sa complexité
et évidemment, ça va dépendre de la taille des données d'entrées
si vous prenez un très grand nombre à factoriser, ça va prendre plus de temps que si le nombre était petit.
Ce que vous voyez ici, c'est une mesure de la complexité du meilleur algorithme dont on dispose pour factoriser un nombre
c'est représenté en échelle logarithmique, hein
et vous voyez que ça augmente très vite, quand le nombre à factoriser devient important.
En 1994, alors que l'ordinateur quantique n'était toujours qu'une idée sur le papier
un chercheur des "Bell labs", Peter Shor, a trouvé un algorithme quantique qui permet de faire de la factorisation en nombre premier.
Alors cet algorithme, je ne vais pas vous le décrire en détail mais évidement, il se base sur un assemblage de portes quantiques
et ce qui est spectaculaire, c'est que sa complexité est bien inférieure à celle du meilleur algorithme classique dont on dispose
vous en voyez, ici, une illustration.
Et plus le nombre de départ est grand, bah plus l'avantage de l'algorithme quantique sera notable, on dit qu'il est exponentiellement meilleur.
Cet algorithme, qu'on appelle l'algorithme de Shor a été un petit coup de tonnerre
parce que sur le papier, il permet de casser la sécurité de toutes les communications chiffrées par RSA.
Enfin sur le papier, on va voir comment ça se passe en pratique.
Tout ce que je vous ai décrit jusqu'ici est assez théorique, je vous ai parlé de q-bits, de portes quantiques, d'algorithme quantiques
mais je vous ai pas dit comment on allait faire concrètement.
Pour faire un ordinateur classique, on l'a vu, on utilise du courant électrique pour faire des bits et soit le courant passe soit il passe pas
mais comment on fait en pratique pour faire un q-bit ?
Et bien il vous faut un système qui puisse être dans 2 états mais qui soit suffisamment petit pour obéir aux lois de la mécanique quantique
et que donc on puisse mettre dans un état superposé.
Il existe différentes manières de faire ça, on peut utiliser par exemple le spin d'un électron ou d'un noyau atomique
la polarisation d'un photon ou bien certains circuits supraconducteurs.
Tout ces objets sont susceptibles de former des q-bits
mais ce qui est compliqué, c'est d'une part d'arriver à en associer suffisamment pour former un registre quantique assez grand
mais surtout de les maintenir isolés du monde extérieur pour qu'ils soient stables et restent dans leur état superposé
du moins suffisamment longtemps pour qu'on puisse faire le calcul dont on a envie.
Et ça c'est pas facile.
Alors petite anecdote personnelle, quand j'ai commencé ma thèse, j'étais dans un institut de physique théorique au Canada
qui est maintenant devenu l'un des hauts lieux de l'informatique quantique
et en 2002, tous les chercheurs du domaine étaient en effervescence parce que pour la première fois
un groupe de recherche dans le monde avait réussi à faire tourner l'algorithme de Shor sur un ordinateur quantique.
L'exploit a eu lieu dans les labos d'IBM en Californie.
Leur ordinateur quantique comportait 7 q-bits et grâce à ça, ils avaient réussi à factoriser le nombre 15.
C'est à dire qu'ils avaient réussi à calculer que 15, c'est 3 fois 5
Mouais, 15 égal 3 fois 5.... Mais ils l'ont trouvé avec un ordinateur quantique
et à partir de ce moment là, ça a été la course pour savoir qui fabriquerait l'ordinateur quantique, le plus gros et le plus puissant.
En 2005, le record est passé à 8 q-bits et en 2006, 12 q-bits.
Mais le moment où on a commencé à entendre vraiment parlé de tout cela, au delà des labos de recherches
c'est en 2011, quand la société canadienne D Wave a annoncé le lancement sur le marché du premier ordinateur quantique
un ordinateur quantique qu'on pouvait acheter.
Alors je vais pas vous refaire toute l'histoire
mais faut savoir qu'il y a eu pas mal de contreverses pour savoir si D Wave avait véritablement fabriqué un ordinateur quantique ou pas.
Il y a beaucoup de spécialistes qui pensent que non et en tout cas que sa rapidité n'était pas du tout ce qu'on attendait d'un véritable ordinateur quantique.
Et il faut aussi savoir que cet ordinateur n'était pas universel, hein, il permettait seulement de résoudre un type de problème bien particulier.
Malgré tout, il y a quelques entreprises, qui en avaient les moyens, qui ont décidés de l'acheter pour l'étudier.
En parallèle de ça, en 2014, on a appris, suite aux révélations d'Edward Snowden
que la NSA, l'agence nationale de sécurité américaine, finançait à hauteur de 80 millions de dollars un programme de recherche sur les ordinateurs quantiques
répondant au doux nom de Penetrating hard target (pénétrer les cibles difficiles)
avec notamment un projet sobrement appelé Owning the Net (posséder le réseau)
Tout un programme!
Mais c'est surtout ces derniers mois que l'excitation autour des ordinateurs quantiques a repris de plus belle.
Toutes les grosses boites, hein, Google, Microsoft, IBM ainsi qu'un certain nombre de start-up issus de labos universitaires
se sont lancés dans la course et construisent des ordinateurs quantiques basés sur différentes technologies.
Toutes ces entreprises courent notamment après un objectif psychologique qu'on appelle "la suprématie quantique".
la "suprématie quantique", ça désigne le jour où, pour la première fois, on arrivera à résoudre avec un ordinateur quantique
quelque chose qu'on n'arrive pas à résoudre avec un ordinateur classique.
Et jusqu'ici, ça a pas encore été le cas.
A part la factorisation en nombre premier
il existe plein de problèmes qu'on pense pouvoir résoudre de manière plus rapide à l'aide d'algorithmes quantiques
qui tourneraient sur des ordinateurs quantiques.
Comme par exemple, des simulations numériques qui permettraient de développer de nouveaux médicaments
ou de mieux comprendre le comportement de la matière au niveau quantique.
Mouais, on utiliserait un ordinateur quantique pour résoudre des problèmes de mécanique quantique, c'est pas beau ça ?
Alors on en est pas encore là, mais à la vitesse où vont les choses, il est bien possible que la suprématie quantique soit atteinte en 2017.
Mais par qui en premier ? Bah les paris sont ouverts.
Merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo, comme d'hab ,n'oubliez pas de vous abonner, si c'est pas déjà fait
Cliquer sur la cloche, si vous êtes déjà abonné, vous pouvez me suivre sur Facebook et Twitter pour avoir les actus de la chaine
Et vous pouvez aussi me soutenir sur Tipee. Merci, à bientôt ;)